nous recevons ce matin olivier weber
bonjour bonjour merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes grand reporter et écrivain
votre livre naissance d'une nation
européenne est sorti fin août il y a
quelques mois vous êtes parti plusieurs
semaines en ukraine vous êtes allé dans
le nord le sud l'est l'ouest vous avez
recueilli de nombreux témoignages
d'ukrainiens de civils de militaires
aussi c'est ce que l'on découvre dans
votre livre mais aussi on y découvre
leur attachement à l'europe le 23 juin
l'ukraine a obtenu le statut de candidat
à l'union européenne c'est une première
étape vous qui avait assisté à la
naissance de l'ukraine moderne il y a
trente ans et depuis vous avez vu c'est
finalement cette volonté d'europe qui
n'a jamais quitté les ukrainiens c'est
ce que vous avez vu notamment oui
absolument ce voyage était assez
lorsqu'il m'a emmené sur les lignes de
front mais aussi à l'arrière dans des
villages dans des villes rare qu'yves
dans de vieux vinyles parler en
particulier puis au dessin est
évidemment j'ai retrouvé des contacts
qui avait milité pour l'indépendance en
1991 et ensuite les différents
événements mais ce qui m'a le plus
surpris peut-être le plus touché c'est
de rencontrer des jeunes de 20 à 25 ans
30 ans qui était à peine qui était
encore ado on va dire pendant les
événements de 2013-2014 de révolution de
maidan et ils m'ont démontré par les
faits par des des jours et des journées
où des nuits de discussions le
rattachement peut-être - l'union
européenne s'est pas levée du livre coco
valeurs européennes la liberté
d'expression la liberté de pensée qui
est un préalable quand même parce qu'en
russie il a avancé que le système
poutinien empêche aussi l'éducation de
la pensée de la critique etc et puis à
l'attachement aux droits de l'homme au
bras de la femme donc ce soit constante
a donc à 25 en cage en informaticiens
qui travaillent l'effort des airs avec
un logiciel pour flécher ou dédiés les
aides humanitaires diverses et variées à
tête village où était le quartier ça
soit pharmaciens que ce soit un soudeur
que ce soit une paysanne tractoriste
j'ai trouvé une sorte de flammes et
d'engagement pour ce qu'on pourrait
appeler l'esprit de résistance quelque
part contre l' agression de la part de
la russie vous écrivez qu'une troisième
l'europe est en train de naître
expliquez-nous qu'est ce qu'on fait oui
bah ses premiers europe une première en
europe avant guerre c'était celle de
romain rolland qui a faim qui s'était
même après
14-18 une volonté de créer quelque chose
autour de l'europe et bien sûr l'union
européenne et puis là il ya une europe
qui a un peu déporté on va dire de
rideau de fer ce n'est pas de son fait
l'ukraine donc a subi cette agression
mais les ukrainiens disent attention le
rideau de fer maintenance et de rideau
qui nous sépare de la russie parce que
c'est là la frontière entre la
démocratie et les aspirations à la vie
démocratique d'une part et puis
deuxièmement le totalitarisme les
dictatures donc il ya un défi pour
l'europe pour les européens s'ils
veulent continuer de plaider les droits
de l'homme ou de la femme il faut
défendre ce pays il faut peut-être aussi
renoncer à quelques acquis quelques
privilèges on verra bien évidemment cet
hiver et que la crise énergétique on
efface un triple au chantage de la part
de poutine on est face à un chantage du
nucléaire le livre d'ailleurs démarre
avec un un homme aux allures de pop
devant la centrale nucléaire il a donc a
dit qu paul il est préfet militaire de
nikopol vont convoyer devant nous les
russes là de kilomètres au delà du
fleuve mais n'est pas du tout prêt
finisterre c'est un chirurgien qui ont
la mine casquette de militaires à bâton
de maréchal on va dire le 24 février qui
défend sa ville chantage également
énergétique bien sûr et puis chantage
alimentaire avec la crise des céréales
en train de se débloquer mais c'est
quand même bien un sou intelligent et là
dessus donc il ya l'europe doit doit
vous qu'andy rage reste unie par rapport
à ce défi par rapport à ce challenge qui
est le le défi d'une europe des valeurs
encore une fois puis une europe de la
liberté vous passez vous demain on va
parler également de 2,2 ce point c'est
cette fatigue de la guerre qui se fait
sentir petit à petit dans tous les sens
du terme on le dit mire les élèves qui
on a parlé récemment dans une interview
est ce qu'on peut craindre que cette
mobilisation européenne s'essouffle
également alors que vous dites justement
qu'il faut que l'europe reste unie à
tout prix si on veut réussir à passer
tous et tout ce qui se passe en ce
moment absolument vous savez moi j'ai
décidé de retourner en ukraine quand
j'étais au printemps donc après le début
de la guerre dans les montagnes à la
frontière afghane avec les résistants
anti talibans est le fils du commandant
massoud et et une guerre chasse l'autre
on parle plus vraiment la guerre
d'afghanistan tout cas la victoire des
talibans sur kaboul et le régime afghan
le 15 août dernier quid de l'ukraine
dont six mois je n'en sais rien c'est
vrai qu'une guerre chasse clos c'est
vrai qu'il ya l'appel l'usure de la
pitié en anglais une sorte voilà de
fatigue par rapport à la compassion et
les ukrainiens sont conscients de cela
évidemment surtout sur les armements et
peut-être encore plus sur les munitions
les militaires les engager les
volontaires la défense territoriale ce
qui patrouillent dans les rues aussi pas
loin des lignes de front dans les
petites villes pour voir s'il n'y a pas
des saboteurs ou des agents de
renseignement à la solde des russes me
disent mais oui on va peut-être manqué
de munitions dans quelques mois et
effectivement pour revenir à l'europe il
peut avoir des failles on sait très bien
qu'on est dans un consensus on va dire
c'est ça l'europe et l'union européenne
et qu'il y aura des failles est compris
dans sur le chantage énergétique peut
être avec la hongrie peut-être avec
l'allemagne peut être écrite à lire et
je crois que c'est important aussi de
peut-être pas de raison garder il ya
même pas de rationnel dans les cas là
c'est une question encore une fois
d'engagement donc lui je crois qu'il
faut garder un cap c'est très important
sachant que c'est très bien que les
intentions de poutine s'était pas
simplement l'ukraine c'était aussi la
moldavie c'était peut-être la roumanie
sûrement les pays baltes donc là
évidemment il n'est pas dans le registre
delà de la victoire mais en tout cas on
peut redouter aussi le syndrome d'une
sorte de bête blessée ch n'est pas eu
raison je n'ai pas eu gain de cause avec
la guerre éclair ce soit qui ait
évidemment échoué on voit bien dans une
guerre d'attrition guerre d'usure une
guerre de position est d'ailleurs les
armées sont bien meilleures en défense
et à l'armée russe qu'en attaque mais
voilà on peut aussi craindre quelques
sursauts quelques nouveaux chantages
pourquoi vous parlez de vladimir poutine
on les a pourquoi cet acharnement du
président russe
il ya et je pense d'abord qu'il n'a
entendu qu'est ce qu'ils voulaient
entendre de la part de gares asimov les
chefs d'état-major d'apparat du cho oyu
élise la défense n'est pas du toit un
militaire d'ailleurs et donc il était
pratiquement certain d'obtenir une
victoire sur kiev est sur une bonne
partie du crâne donc là c'est quand même
des faits tout un ensemble de des faits
selon qu'on puisse dire on est dans une
guerre de position et je crois que c'est
aussi une question d'abord de postures
psychologique un dictateur ou le
potentat qui a été mise en défaut et
puis deuxièmement peut-être aussi une
question de survie du régime donc si la
fuite en avant et ça c'est très
dangereux on l'a vu dans l'histoire
contemporaine donc et un acharnement et
puis il ya aussi deuxièmement une
inversion du discours la russie quand je
lis et la russie si elle à la russie de
poutine le système poutinien du kremlin
a dit mme c'est nous les adresser nous
sommes agressées et nous sommes des
victimes et c'est très dangereux parce
que c'est aussi l'histoire contemporaine
nous a montré au xxème siècle sur ce nom
que un pays qui a agressé qui se décrit
un agresseur pardon qui se dit victime
ça peut créer la pire des barbaries ce
qu'on découvre aussi dans votre livre
vous l'évoquez à plusieurs reprises
c'est cette détermination la
détermination des ukrainiens à se battre
à se battre pour cette liberté pour ses
valeurs européennes et vladimir poutine
ne s'y attendait pas du tout et ça vous
l'avez constaté dans toutes les
rencontres que vous avez pu faire au
cours de votre séjour on est absolument
c'est ce qui m'a marqué parce que cette
détermination alors qu'on soit l'arrière
soit un tracteur dans une ferme où qu'on
soit l'avant pour rappel un paysagiste
donc architecte paysagiste qui s'est
engagée la diversité territoriale des
ingénieurs j'ai vu des médecins j'ai eu
des chômeurs et tous deux 20 ans à 60
ans sont dédiés donc à ce qu'on pourrait
appeler l'effort de guerre vous rappeler
en 14-18 ont parlé de l'effet l'arrière
qui tiendra avec surtout des femmes en
france qu'il fabriquait l'aimez vous
évoluer sa carrière voilà absolument il
a séparé les l'arrière tiendra et je ne
pense pas qu'il puisse y avoir gain de
cause de la part de l'armée russe sur la
conquête des territoires où le maintien
en zone occupée des ukrainiens
d'ailleurs marqué des points
actuellement bon là c'est du court terme
sur quartier on a vu les images tout à
l'heure cet hymne national ainsi voilà
absolument sur carson ya aussi des
actions de saboteurs très souvent et au
moins une quarantaine de tentative
d'assassinât sur des dirigeants pro
russe on va dire de l'administration qui
mise en place pour russie puis on va
dire ces zones donc il ya beaucoup
d'audace il ya beaucoup d'avant évitez
pu répondre à votre question oui de 20
ans à 60 ans j'ai vraiment senti cet
engagement à vouloir défendre la nation
et c'est pas du nationalisme c'est du
patriotisme j'avais avec moi pendant ces
semaines de voyage un roman qui met
beaucoup touché j'ai lu il ya longtemps
qu est le premier au moindre le premier
roman de romain gary éducation
européenne qui l'a écrit lorsqu'il était
jeune aviateur pendant la france libre
en 1943 donc la halle ont lorsqu'ils
revenaient d'une mission la nuit et ça
se passe à peu près dans cette région en
pologne en galicie l'actuelle ukraine
aujourd'hui avec des maquisards qui
combattent les nazis allemands et est ce
que dit l'un des patriotes il dit bah le
nationalisme c'est détester les autres
le patriotisme ce que nous revendiquons
nous les patriotes les partisans entier
nazis c'est aimer l'autre et c'est ce
qui se passe aussi en ukraine ya une
défense on va dire presque universel des
valeurs et j'étais étonné parce que les
jeunes disent maintenant on ne veut plus
jamais entendre parler de l'holodomor le
doma en deux secondes c'était quoi c'est
la famille des années 30 qui est
orchestrée par staline pour mettre au
pas les paysans mais aussi l'ensemble de
la population ukrainienne qu'on trouvait
à moscou au temps de l'urss totalement
retorse est relative et indépendantistes
et bien ça fait quatre morts en des
comptes à l'époque les 22 24 millions
d'habitants et les jeunes de 20 ans 25
ans qui soit intellectuel ou chômeurs
ouvriers paysans disent on ne veut plus
jamais entendre parler de ça c'est un
tabou il ya encore 10 ou 20 ans on ne
met un terme aux joues galets tutelle de
l'ancienne mère-patrie qui est la russie
d'aujourd'hui et malgré tout ce qui se
passe je vous cite un nul n dans ses
propos contre le peuple russe bien au
contraire mais une volonté profonde de
lutter contre la dictature de poutine en
dissociant le régime de la population ça
aussi vous l'avez constaté oui j'ai
constaté avec des bémols ce que j'ai
même des amis ukrainiens qui me
reprochent de citer un peu trop souvent
des auteurs russes alors google et
ukrainiens mais il ya pouchkine tolstoï
dostoïevski mais je crois qu'il ne faut
pas condamner la rue s'il faut pas
condamner les arts russe ne faut pas
qu'on ait la population russe même si
une bonne partie évidemment de gré ou de
force et derrière le narratif de poutine
qui est un narratif très offensif très
gras très nationaliste et populiste et
dangereux agressif et martial mais je
crois qu'il faut vraiment dissocier les
deux le système poutine le pouvoir qui
est pouvoir de ce que j'ai appelé dans
le livre un néo empire un ancien empire
tsariste com ce qu'il redevient empire
expansionniste de la population qui voit
là représente une histoire millénaire
qui doivent constater évidemment qu'il
ya une césure avec le peuple ukrainien
ce n'est pas la même chose bien qu' il
ya beaucoup de mariages on dit qu'à un
ukrainien et russe pardon sur cinq ou
six qui donc j'ai une chrétienne par des
liens de famille ou des liens de sang
etc et mais en tout cas là il ya un
divorce qui est évident à cause de la
guerre et en même temps il faut pas
condamner ni la russie ni la culture
russe évidemment un mot sur à la
centrale de deux appareils déjà là il ya
demande à ce que la zone soit sécurisée
lagence jugent la situation intenable
déjà à l'époque de votre séjour en
ukraine vous aviez pu constater vous
aussi les habitants vous avez parlé de
cette crainte qu'ils avaient du fait que
les russes ses biens avaient occupé
cette centrale oui très fort parce que
j'étais le côté du fleuve donc avec les
amis ukrainiens et puis le préfet
militaire qui est même le jeune maire de
nikopol alexander seuil ou qui est un
ancien homme d'affaires de 38 40 ans et
me disais mais si jamais il ya cotisent
passe dans la centrale fukushima n'ont
été qu'une vaste plaisanterie il était
très très inquiet c'était en mars et en
avril et à l'époque je me disais aussi
le maire de nikopol donc en face de la
centrale c'est que en temps de paix nous
avons trois équipes d'ukrainiens
ingénieurs et techniciens qui
travaillent énormément mais en se
relayant bien sûr actuellement nous
n'avons plus qu'une équipe quitte à tirs
tendus qui est fatigués qui est oppressé
et des arrestations parce que certains
de ces techniciens envoyer des images
l'autre côté pour dire regardez ce qui
se passe il ya quand même l'arrivée de
transport de troupes il ya un stockage
de munitions dans la centrale ya des
provocations on pense qu'il ya même eu
des cas de torture sur certains d'entre
eux donc lui grande inquiétude à
l'époque c'était enfin c'est une
tentative d'ailleurs de débarquement de
russes sur l'autre rive donc la rive
droite du nieppe à ce moment là repoussé
donc avec des amphibie euro poussé par
les ukrainiens c'est très tendu mais
évidemment il ya une gradation avec le
mois d'août et cette instrumentalisation
de la question du nucléaire qui est
unique dans l'histoire quand on prend
initié au cours dans l'histoire elle est
très grave
et j'espère que l' agence internationale
de l'énergie atomique pour à pérenniser
sa présence est 2e enquêter sur les deux
agents qui sont sur place du reste est
tout à fait c'est aussi la diplomatie et
parce que grossi le directeur de
l'agencé de vienne négocier avec les
russes pour les passages c'est vrai mais
je pense qu'on saura prochainement d'où
viennent les tirs c'est important et
puis évidemment démilitarisé
neutraliser en quelque sorte cette
centrale qui doit pas être l'objet d'une
guerre merci beaucoup olivier weber
d'avoir été avec nous rappelle le titre
de votre livre à naissance d'une nation
européenne rester avec nous on se
retrouve dans quelques minutes pour la
suite de paris direct